- How did this ever become a trend?
Let's just tie rope around our necks,
but fancy rope.
- So today, I'm tying a
tie for the first time.
A man in a tie is like the best thing.
- I don't know why, it's like a weird
large shoelace hanging from your neck
- I think I can do it.
I don't think it's that hard.
- I'm predicting that I'm going to fail
at this miserably.
- So I feel like I should
flip this up first.
- Oh, that's why they do this.
- So this is the Windsor Knot.
I thought that these were
each different knots,
but it's actually all steps.
- So this has to be...
- Wait.
- I'm doing this correct?
- No, I'm doing it all wrong.
- No, no, I'm not.
I'm so not.
- Over to the, so wait, oh.
- Oh, let's just say it's this.
- Oh my God, I think I got it.
I did it.
- Oh shit.
- I would really like
to try that over again.
- I do that move all
the guys do on Mad Men.
- It's not that hard people.
- I messed up the ends.
- And I'm just gonna hide
this one in my shirt.
- Pretty easy.
Give me a harder one.
- This is the Eldredge Knot.
- Yes, I went to the Eldredge last night
for some peanuts and a cocktail.
- It has 15 fucking steps.
- And you're gonna whip
it around town like this.
- Then through the loop
made in the previous step.
I made a loop?
- It just keeps going.
- The ties don't wrinkle
because this is ridiculous.
- Keep this part loose.
- It's all loose.
It's not really, why would I, sure.
- I have like three more steps to go.
- If I just put my collar
down, no one will notice.
- I look great.
The tie doesn't.
- Come at me, Eldredge.
What now?
- This is a bow tie.
I'm nervous for this one because
it looks really (bleep) complicated.
- Anyone who knows how to do this has my
complete, utter respect.
- Bow ties are not sexy.
You just look like a penguin.
- How the hell did we ever
come up with this as a society?
- I don't even know what
that next picture means.
- I feel like you need more fingers.
- Oh shit.
- I had to learn how
to do winged eyeliner.
Was that easy? No.
- I'm like choking myself.
- Okay, where the hell am I?
- Let's just say I did it.
It looks like a bow.
- I feel like Fred Flintstone.
- But you'll notice that
this is not correct.
- It's an ascot.
This isn't a bow tie at all.
- I never knew how hard
Pee Wee Herman had it.
- Definitely takes a lot
of foresight going into it.
- But once you actually
try it, it's not that hard,
except for bow ties.
Those are awful.
- I never want to wear
another one of these again.
- To men who tie their
tie on a daily basis,
I salute you, this is hard.
- Next time I see a guy in (mumbles),
I'm just gonna give him
like five high fives
and be like, "That was like really hard,
"You did so good."
- This is really tight.
- No wonder this is the signature
"I'm home" move.